hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to blank dream again also
welcome back is what I meant to say so
young lady you're remembering who you
are bit by bit get back our memories
grant our wish what will happen to us
deceased after that surely will be at
peace and go to heaven it well maybe not
maybe you'll be stuck in purgatory
and/or hell forever and ever and ever
deep in the realms huh I've always
stayed away because of all the evil
spirits yeah no joke they come out of
the pool with the walls does that stuff
not bother you mashiro nah I am done its
bladder of Steel and balls of iron and
nickel
[ __ ] [ __ ] I can't come up with
clever commentary so I cover it with
vulgarity that's what I do
that's what I do alright whatever you're
oh hello I an angel like Statutes
deteriorated with parts missing an angel
AG stench oh oh I wonder oh oh I wonder
Hopa dupa dupa oh oh no it couldn't be
it's lichen witch's house in there was
that one red spot in the middle and it
actually scared me like of course the
one red spot in the middle of course it
means something that is equivalent to
death did I speak to these goddamnit I
didn't look oh god I know I talk to you
again really me blue blue bah bah bah
okay I get a double on both of them just
in case it was any hidden commentary
there I did that totally intentionally
and no one can question anything that I
do ever okay I'll talk to these guys I
did this do daddy can go in here what am
i oh I don't like you the teddy bear
stairs with round eyes again not very
cute but there's something about all
these teddy bears that I'm gonna need to
remember in the future obviously okay
there was a distant sound good there was
a lot of other things too but at least
there's that
come for me in my darkest of days
don't you dare don't you freaking dare
oh oh oh don't you dare oh don't you
dare come closer to me oh I won't have
any of this where are you no you no no
no no no see nothing bro I see oh I see
oh I see okay all right okay all right
Oh God I gotta move gotta move gotta
move Oh titty titty titty oh oh it was
so scary I was so scared it was a scary
scary I'm gonna get him I got him
yes oh look at me look at me later game
the shells only have broken and dirty
bottles good I don't care about that
take it okay I got a bottle look blue
paint good who are you I don't know get
out I would rather do that okay oh here
we go
will you look at that here we go okay
all righty then I'm gonna go back and
save cuz damn I wonder if there was
another secret somewhere in there
because odd there him hot diggity Doo
Dah Diana do alright anyway what else
you got in here
what else you got for me are you back
here
okay I bet there's something in here
this would totally make sense that there
was a secret but it might not be here
now might have only been here when that
girl was patrolling which would be bad
because then I'm wasting my time here
but I just want to make sure I want to
be as thorough as possible here because
hot-diggity-dog man I love it when I
love it when these RPG horror games get
a little creative with it because I mean
obviously they're all working with a
very limited set of stove hey how's it
going there
very limited serve something they got a
wave a rising wave of artistry stirs in
me don't mind me I'm gonna wax poetic
and spout [ __ ] my arm is a divide
here I go my arm is a divine tool
creating life with brush and paint it is
my duty to paint life's beauty on the
white surface someone anyone will do
bring me paint the root of life to me oh
the art it flows through my veins like
blood gushing out of who now mmm
and I can't come up with good commentary
cuz I'm a [ __ ] idiot
oh that is blue paint the blue paint was
snatched away good good
but not yet I like the colors for full
expression nor oh bring more paints the
root of life the root of my soul the
root of everything I have dark old beer
in my heart okay you know I'm for that
[ __ ] what do we got here what do we
got here
hello oh this looks good I love all
these narrow corridors they're the best
I am the living painting Julia mariya I
can speak and blood even runs through me
great that's not weird I'm okay with
this the hardly holds any meeting in
this lonely place but at least stay with
me for a bit oh I'll burn you know maybe
I'll maybe I'll come back maybe I'll
come back maybe I'll come back before I
just start knifing paintings with blood
flowing through them which I'm assuming
I would use for he choose wisely
now I'm not I'm not an expert on these
subjects but I think I know a trick
question when I see one and when I see
what I'm gonna go save before I do
anything stupid now because I know I
know that it's probably probably the one
with a blood stain but outside is also
the one could here we go
oh damn it I thought it was gonna be the
opposite because of a trick question you
know it can't be that obvious or else
it'd be everyone could get it only a
smart Smarties would get okay all right
never mind
I'm just done I'm just a big dummy I'm a
big dumb dummy do all modem damn it did
no well it was a trick I knew it I knew
that was gonna be I knew it's gonna be a
trick I just didn't guess what trick it
was I was too stupid to recognize that
it wasn't either the choices I made
anyway okay oh oh okay oh okay oh great
stuff god damn it again with that why
did that happen what was the point of
that okay so I got an empty bottle now I
can stab the stab the frick fracking
thing and take its blood cuz that's
really nice of me but I do so now I'm
gonna gonna stab Oh Julia Marya that
name sounds familiar I don't know if it
has any meaning though
okay here we go ah why did I do this you
how could you for what I don't know I'm
a terrible person
I'm terrible I'm a terrible person
I'm the worst oh don't try to tell me
you did this for that over terrible
person
oh no oh no I'm so bad bad markiplier
bad you're a bad boy no it's not there
was probably another way oh no oh no oh
oh yeah it's not good it's not good it's
not good it's not good it's not good oh
oh it's not good
oh it's not good oh it's not good oh I
feel so bad it was it was a living
painting it was a rare thing oh
containers full of ordinary water like
liquid oh great
okay all right
maybe I could have done something else
for that maybe I could have wool boy
hello
are you gonna kill me nope all right
clean up after yourself I try be not
greedy okay tsu'tey box is empty
tsu'tey box contains an old plank it's
heavy but not impossible to carry many
broken and dirty bottles lined the
shelves with a one clean one you dokie
then so be not greedy hmm shall I take
this weighty gold with me Charlie
Oh impressive thickness ha there's Noah
I've no jokes about this okay I got the
gold Hey
aah I thought for sure it would have
been Zee good oh because I'm dead
through here ok anyway I take all my
terrible jokes with me to the grave all
right try this one more time this time
less stupidly I knew what I needed to do
okay got it okay boo boo boo boo boo boo
boo boo don't nice the gap fine okay got
it
and then don't be greedy don't be greedy
huh and I'm good what at all we didn't
put the plank okay I know what I needed
Oz like what you Sunda [ __ ] that was
not part of the agreement how dare you
how dare you okay I got it
so yeah I need to clean up after myself
you guys are a stickler for these all
right
okay yep okay got it and then put it
back what nope nothing absolutely minute
why is where'd my plane go I have it why
can't to put it back
oh yeah isn't often no not that one okay
whose is down below not god damn stop
trying to knife I'm trying a knife
everything murder is not the only option
here all right here we go
thank you okay I'll be on my way now
thank you very much thank you very much
okay Kluber to move scooped up the
liquid something tells me that wasn't
just water that was a bit too squishy to
be water blip right oh good oh I like it
Boyd you're buzzin Oh God
is it a good wait there's something I'm
supposed to do about this I'm assuming
oh okay
oh those it I thought there was
something to that I guess not but I mean
what was the point of all that if I was
just to make more French okay no how
about no that's gotta be something to
that oh oh oh oh that was it that was it
for you oh you son of a [ __ ] you son of
a [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
what do you think black paint red blue
and black okay yes yes with this paint
alone I can create life but what about
all the other ones wait
wait but did I not need okay you are
using oh is it Sonic is that Sonic dot
exe is that song key but behold this is
my art the child I have birth
perhaps I have no regrets now gods
demons take this rotten soul as food for
art huh did he explode into blood
Vidya burst in blood bro did it his
burst in blood I'm gonna go check up on
that painting just to be sure
hello friend oh yeah that's right dad
dad no good hmm that no good at all okay
so moving on moving on I [ __ ] you right
okay I see how it is
I see how this toy that's actually all
the time that I have for this episode
here thank you everybody so much for
watching I really hope you're enjoying
this one this is a really really really
good into your game or RPG horror maker
view it's really good I love this one to
death so thank you again let me know how
I'm doing in the comments below and as
always see you in the next video
back to the time Hey